I turned to my right and I see from
bleach report the senior NBA reporter
man who spent many many years with the
New York Times here in this town good to
see you Howard Beck what's going on
good to see you rich thank you I just
I'm honored to be in the seat that was
occupied by Brian Koppelman just 24
hours ago this is awesome
yes it's not sure I'm worthy you're a
billions fan as well a huge huge
billions fan and also of course a huge
wire fan so the fact that Michael Kate
Williams will be in later we're not
gonna cross paths kind of um yeah oh
it's okay
timings everything in life so but I'm
pleased to have you here right now your
piece and bleach report was
thought-provoking to say the least
it gave voice to what I have been
thinking for quite some time and a lot
of people are not really talking about
is that anybody who wants to sign a free
agent contract and play basketball in
Los Angeles or New York City have much
better options than the standard-bearer
teams of those towns in the Lakers and
the Knicks when you've got the Clippers
and the nets what's been the feedback
and the fallout that you have seen from
your piece no feedback or fallout as of
yet I'm sure there were probably a few
people who were not quite happy with the
results of my reporting because of the
folks that I interviewed around the
league
obviously all anonymously other
executives scouts assessing the four
teams the Nets and Clippers rated out
very highly people really have high
regard for what those two teams are
building right now rich and for good
reason right they're winning the
Clippers are in the playoffs the Nets
still have a shot they've got great
front office's coaching ownership is all
stable and the Knicks and Lakers yeah
they're the glamor teams they're that
the institutional icons but they both
have some you know some issues and some
dysfunction in recent years they've been
dealing with him in the next for a long
time with the next for a long time I'm
sure those organizations weren't weren't
pleased with the story I haven't heard
anything back but I it to your point if
you're afraid in this summer and there
are some big ones yeah you've got
options that you never would have had
before because the Clippers and nets
were always either afterthoughts or a
punch line both and they're actually
both in a very healthy spot right now
well that also assumes that players who
are free on July 1st to
go on a free agency so free agency tour
are susceptible to being wooed that they
can be brought into a team can be
pitched by a team like the nets like the
Clippers and sake choose us because of X
Y & Z Clippers can put Jerry West out
there the Nets can put obviously their
last couple of years track record out
there Ric Bucher colleague of yours and
mine and the NR in our industry is
saying the ranks a done deal to the next
what do you say on that front well I
will say this I think it's ever it's
hard to say done deal when we are in
what April but even if you rolled back
to February January if you asked around
the league at any time this season the
consensus astute is too light of a word
the overwhelming opinion of people
around the league is yes Kevin Durant is
leaving the Warriors after the season
and he's going to New York now
the NBA grapevine is very active and and
it's it's sometimes right and it's
sometimes not and sometimes you wonder
if it's a game of telephone and
everyone's just sharing the same tidbits
of information I've never heard it this
definitive on a player's future as I
have with the idea of Durant to the
Knicks it's everyone you ask and there
is certainty
now when I say certainty I mean that
that's what the people executives and
scouts will tell you but nobody really
knows of course I even Kevin Durant
probably doesn't know and if you ask
folks who were around him during his
final year in Oklahoma he wavered
throughout that season and after that
season in making his decision to leave
there to go to Golden State in the first
place so we're not talking about the
most reliable narrator in Kevin Durant
so even if he or people associate with
him have indicated that that's what he
wants to do there's a lot of time for
that to change
I would agree I mean why wouldn't he
stay put why wouldn't he it's a great
question you know and they answer every
time I say that is what legacy well he
joined a team that had already won a
championship and did put it into a
different a different stratosphere but
that's just because he's as good as he
is and everybody else is as good as they
are he just joined he joined the team
that beat him yeah and he needs to
create his own
spot his own legacy in his own new town
and I'm like well why doesn't he just
christen the new beautiful arena that
they're gonna have in San Francisco the
rest of the team might change he's still
there he's the one who's won this the
MVPs of the NBA Finals why can't his
legacy just be what he's done
continued on it's funny if you go back
through MBA history and you talk about
all-time greats and the championships
they won whether it was the 11 rings
that the Celtics won back in the 60s or
you know the Lakers Showtime teams of
the 80s the Bulls in the 90s any of them
you never talk about how those players
got there what their decisions were in
the course there you just know that they
have rings you just know when you flip
through the the annals or you you're
scrolling on Twitter right oh yeah that
guy's got four rings five rings he's in
the Hall of Fame the details don't
matter the details fade away so if
Durant is concerned with legacy and how
he's gonna per be perceived in relation
to that Warriors dynasty it's silly
really if the idea is to win at the
highest level as much as you can yeah in
the years that you have available to you
grab as many rings as you can there's no
reason he should still leave and last
night in the game in Los Angeles I don't
know if you saw the the highlight from
last night Christmas I'm talking a
little Braun I mean what and and and I
you know we hit that at the top of the
show as well about the the talking to
LeBron it's not that these two guys who
absolutely definitely have each other's
cell phone numbers would choose in
public on the floor of Staples to cover
their mouth and say hey you gonna come
here to Long July one like that
conversation if it's odd is had
elsewhere I think what they're actually
doing is they're pulling up the the
thing and they're going if we both do
this people are laughing about it but
the other those that was one item from
last night another one was Steph Curry
behind the back no look full court pass
to Durant wide open for a bucket good
luck finding that somewhere else
with that guy can also shoot threes and
that guy is also an MVP caliber player
and human being
like good luck with that I don't mean to
the Knicks
even if Kyrie comes that's still not as
likely as anywhere else for him to find
probably not and and this is the thing
we have always assumed rich as as fans
of the game as media who covered the
game that it's always all about winning
or we play into that a lot we really
know better where we all should know
better by now it's never just about the
championships and the winning it can be
about the money of course it can be
about ego it can be about branding and
your personal brand it can be about
business opportunities off the court it
can be about a lot of different things
and just as a lot of people believe that
LeBron went to the Lakers for reasons
other than championships other than
basketball and winning at the highest
level people believe that with Durant
ends up with the Knicks it has nothing
to do with trying to contend because why
how could it the Knicks haven't done
anything in a very long time and they
have been a model of dysfunction for a
very long time and we could get into
this but I also think that if he comes
to the Knicks I don't know how I don't
know where they're actually going to be
we push that one to the side for a
second but the fact is if he comes to
New York it has to be because of things
that are not basketball because if it
was just about basketball and winning at
the highest level you would stay with
the Warriors or you could play with
LeBron with the Lakers or you could go
to the Nets there's two teams that are
much further along in their development
and have a supporting cast ready there
and both the Clippers and nets if they
want to can create a second max slot now
you end up losing some of those players
who have been playing so well this year
you but you'd still have a good core
left around you whereas with the Knicks
there's just nothing there right now
there's some maybe future promise with
some young guys but there's nothing you
can say I could definitely win something
with that guy Howard back here on the
Rich Eisen show let me throw the bone to
mix fans as well as the front office
that might not be very pleased with your
your piece and anybody who's heard me
talk about James Dolan on that show and
I will not go down a wormhole Zion comes
we'll know that before July 1st yeah
Kyrie wants to come back to this area he
does make that decision he calls Durant
you go I go
let's go play with Zion I mean that is
the that's the best-case scenario for
the Knicks and fizzed Ale is an
excellent coach I really like him why
why isn't that in the realm of
possibility that seems to me like a
really realistic scenario here that's in
the realm of possibility and if they got
the dream scenario that's Kady
Kyrie Zion they're a very good place and
the potential for that team to then be a
contender in the East I say is is is
strong I would not say it's automatic
this town would go crazy so here here
I'm gonna in the middle of July I mean
for sure a few caveats on this one not
everybody believes ioan is destined for
stardom in the NBA destined for for
something really good and impactful yes
come on really not everybody it's not a
certainty it's not a certainty we'll see
we'll see sweets a freak of me I know
but we do this sometimes but we do this
sometimes we crown guys a little ahead
Andrew Wiggins was supposed to like
change the world be the next LeBron
Andrew Wiggins is not good so I just yes
this is not to to cast doubt on Zion at
all this is just to say that I'm you
this this is just my general caution as
a reporter yes let's not get ahead of
ourselves but if they got the draft
rights design if they got the top pick
in the draft that also gives the ability
to make a trade for maybe Anthony Davis
or somebody else out there who's
available because this is the second
caveat
youth doesn't win in the NBA it just
doesn't and if Kevin Durant and Kyrie
Irving are coming to New York to the to
max slots that are open with their to
max salaries yes by the math I think
means okay now you're maxed out you you
have no more cap room so we've you've
now renounced the rights to DeAndre
Jordan you're only veteran player who
has any any experience at a high level
so you're starting from scratch with the
rest the roster mitchell robinson looks
really good but he's young and he's
still kind of raw dennis smith jr a lot
of doubts about him around the league
Kevin Knox there's some troubling signs
through his rookie season and I've heard
a lot about his lack of motor from
inside that building so you need a
supporting cast at KD and Kyrie know
this better than anyone
Katy Kyrie and Zion as a rookie
exciting but are they gonna be able to
win at the highest level immediately I
don't know
youth doesn't generally win can you flip
sign for ad or other high-powered elite
talent who are veterans can you turn
Kevin Knox and some pics into veterans
because you're gonna need a veteran cast
if you're gonna try to take down and
let's just assume stability with the
rest of the top of the best let's assume
that the Bucks keep their supporting
cast you want to knock off Yanis in that
group you're gonna need a veteran crew
you want to knock off Philly if they
keep Tobias Harris and Jimmy Butler and
still have em beat in Simmons you're not
doing it with a bunch of kids you want
to compete with Toronto if kauai stays
you're not doing it with a young roster
that you're just taking off the you know
the scrapheap with what's left of your
like I said you don't have cap room you
have cap exceptions at that point
minimum salaries they need to put
together a full team not just a couple
of stars we've seen this in the NBA
just one stars never enough two stars
and a bad supporting cast can get you
knocked out in the first round look at
the Oklahoma City Thunder
they've got Russell Westbrook and Paul
George two of the top 10 players in the
NBA arguably mm-hmm
they're going to finish in the seventh
or eighth slot in the West and they're
probably out in the first round and look
at the Lakers they've got LeBron and a
bunch of young players that we have no
idea how that's gonna all work out
Howard Becca bleach report here on the
Rich Eisen show let's finish up our
conversation with the Bucs they did
clinch best record throughout in the NBA
so how viable are they as in Eastern
Conference champion that can go west and
throwing the Warriors how how realistic
is that this is what I love about the
Bucs rich and about this season in
general now LeBron is out of the East
and we've seen this wide open race now
yes the Bucks can't emerge and and
should be the favorites to emerge for
obvious reasons they gotta top defense
one of the top offenses best record all
that but Philly and Boston yes I still
believe in Boston and Toronto are all
legit to come out of the East as well
we'll see how it plays out matchup saw
something to do with it health lock all
that stuff what I love about the Bucks
in particular though is that they might
just upend this super team era we are so
used to this now where you have to have
two guys three guys in the case of the
Warriors
for guys the Bucks have won all due
respect to Chris Middleton who made the
all-star team and the rest that cast
good players but no it's this is not
Wade LeBron and Bosh this is not kuri
Durant green and and clay
this is Jana sand a perfectly calibrated
supporting cast with the exact right
coach who got the most out of them and
if they can emerge from the East that's
a victory already for small markets and
four teams doing it a different way if
they can somehow you know push the
Warriors and yes I'm assuming the
Warriors if they can push them to six
games in the finals if they can somehow
beat them in the finals I just we need
that we need somebody to finally prove
there's a different way to win that
there's an antidote to the super team
because not everybody can build a super
team and especially smaller markets or
the non glamour markets as I call them
they need a different formula they need
to know that it's possible to have any
hope because it's it's tough in today's
NBA especially when guys are
conglomerating in the big markets and
you got the Bucks owner on your pod he's
coming on your pod Marc Lasry coming on
the podcast today yes looking forward to
and his name was mentioned by Brian
Koppelman bringing this whole thing full
circle it all has been co-creators of
billions saying that he reached that he
and David Levine the co-creators were on
the show yesterday reached out to him to
just get into the mind of a billionaire
and what's it like to be in that
stratosphere they've consulted with a
bunch of them including Marc Lasry
and I will be asking him about that at
length of course on the podcast cuz all
roads eventually lead back to billions
as we know I agree thanks for coming on
in person Howard absolutely live in here
let's keep chatting throughout the
playoffs that are going to begin very
shortly again check out all of Howard's
stuff on twitter at howard back at
bleacher report as well right here on
the Rich Eisen show on BR live the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience